Bud Light baby Bud Light is getting
absolutely wrecked still Bud Light sales
it's not just that they dropped in the
week after transheiser Bush decided to
endorse a drag queen
or a transvestite or whatever whatever
Dylan wolf any calls himself it's
it's not just that they dropped and then
they went back up it's not even just
that they dropped and they stayed where
they were they dropped and then they
kept dropping and then they kept
dropping and then it looked like they
kind of had cratered but no they kept
dropping they've crept they've kept
dropping again sales revenue plunge 26.8
percent
in the week ending June 10th according
to new data that is a new low
for weekly sales revenue the previous
highest weekly drop for Bud Light was
25.7 percent
and now 26.8 so what is Bud Light doing
what is transheiser Bush doing first of
all I think that company owes Alyssa
hershenfeld or whatever that VP of
marketing was they owe her an apology
because she took the fall for this but
this is obviously a conscious decision
by transheiser Bush made it a much
higher level than the VP of marketing so
why are they doing it
why would Bud Light consistently
irritate the customers and not just
apologize
because
Bud Light has to keep up it's ESG score
transheiser Bush ESG the environmental
social governance policies which is a
term that will probably fall out of
favor now the conservatives have seized
upon it and they'll replace it with some
new woke jargon but
what these scores
mean is that left-wing groups will score
companies on a whole host of progressive
priorities and then the big asset
managers the big institutional investors
that that manage tens of trillions of
dollars worth worth of money each
they could pull their money out of the
companies and so you say well who cares
who cares if BlackRock or somebody pulls
its money out of a b inbap transcisor
Bush ABN Bev is a big company they're
still selling beer who cares who needs
blackrock's money well what would happen
is the top stock break would would tank
it would show a lack of faith in the
company from the biggest players in the
market
so the company would just go away and so
you've got a handful of major asset
managers BlackRock State Street Vanguard
and others who are really pulling the
strings here and they're not answering
to their customers and they're not
answering to their constituents if it
were a political body like a government
body they're just doing whatever they
want
now why would they do this but another
reason that they would be willing to
kill Bud Light the most popular beer in
America is that Bud Light had not been
growing it had not been explosively
growing it was still the dominant number
one beer in America but some of the
executives felt that it was it was
stagnating and you saw this represented
by Alyssa hershenfeld the VP of
marketing who said we needed to do
something to Jazz up the brand why did
they have to do that well because the
way that modern capitalism works it's
not enough to be the biggest dogs in
town you've got to always be growing if
you're not growing then you're dying and
and and this creates a problem because
there's no there's no limit to it
there's no limit anywhere and so
what this might be is a controlled
demolition of Budweiser because while
ABM Bev transheer Bush might take a hit
in the short run there are so few major
beer distributors that in the long run
it probably won't cost them all that
much money
the number one beer in America now is
Modelo which is hilarious that it's a
Mexican beer that's now the number one
beer in in America and Modelo is not
owned by transheiser Bush in North
America
it's owned by constellation which also
has some work problems too but in the
rest of the world Modelo is owned by
transheiger Bush and so there's there
these conglomerates own so much product
and there are so few of them anyway that
they've they've just Consolidated enough
power that okay they lose one of their
lines well they've got a bazillion more
lines to fill it up and the benefit they
get from that is they get to advance the
social policies that they want those
social policies by the way we're down to
even more consolidation and even more
control and even more money and even
more influence for these handful of
oligarchs and so the cost to them
is worth it right now go to
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show let
me ask you something when you use the
restroom you always close the door
behind you right you don't want random
passers-by looking in on you so why
would you let people look in on you when
you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the restroom and not
closing the door okay I love expressvpn
I'm a total Luddite so I barely know how
to use any technology but it's so easy
to use even I can use it you just
download it one click of a button on
your cell phone on your laptop on your
on your iPad on whatever you want I can
say with full confidence expressvpn is
the best VPN on the market here's why
number one expressvpn doesn't log your
online activity they even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can stream HD videos with
zero buffering number three expressvpn
is incredibly easy to use
it's that one button you're done you're
good to go if you're like me you believe
your online activity is your business
use our link expressvpn.com Michael
Knowles show today get three months free
in a one-year package
expresvpn.com michaelenles show
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
speaking of BlackRock James O'Keefe
formerly of project Veritas who's now
doing his own thing OMG which is the
O'Keefe Media Group it's a fun little
fun little initialism there uh James has
caught a black rock recruiter on hidden
camera
explaining what BlackRock really is from
the inside
let me tell you it's not that it was the
president
it's controlling the wall
[Music]
and who's that the hedge funds across
the banks
contained financing
yep you can find your candidates
obviously we have this system in place
first there's the sentence
you got 10 grand you can buy yourself I
could give you 500k right now no
questions asked yeah
just like everybody do that does
Blackhawk do that it doesn't matter who
wins
Ukraine is good for business
all right I'll give an example Russia
Russia blows up Ukraine's grains price
of wheat's gonna go mad up Ukrainian
economy is inside very largely for wheat
Market Global wheat market prices of
bread and you know literally everything
is it goes up and down this is fantastic
if you're trading
volatility creates opportunity to make
profit business
great stuff from James
it's nothing we didn't know
there's nothing surprising in this
undercover video
yes we know people can buy politicians
U.S senators I think cost more than ten
thousand dollars to influence and there
are some politicians who can take the
money and then they won't
take the phone calls and then sometimes
the people who previously backed them
will back their opponents or something I
mean there are some more independent
voices but yeah it's true and very often
what politicians will do in their
defense is they will seek out donors who
share their priorities
so that it's not just that they're being
bought off like a cheap hooker or
something like that it's that they are
representing multiple kinds of
constituents they're representing their
Geographic constituents they're
representing interests that they already
support you know if I I make fun of the
the environmentalist movement that
people who say Global warm is going to
kill us all in five minutes I I mock
some of these new technologies
especially the solar and electric
technologies that are very often just
payoffs to Liberal groups so I'm I'm Pro
fossil fuels I'm Pro oil and natural gas
if I were to run for office
and I I received a campaign donation
from oil and natural gas Industries
I it wouldn't be that they were buying
me off I'm I'm already Pro oil and
natural gas they've never written me any
campaign check but it's a nice alignment
of values and sometimes it's a little
more corrupt than that sometimes it's
just a big corporation that says hey I'm
you know here's the check do what I want
give me the legislation that helps me
okay yeah but we are we already know all
that what about the Ukraine war is good
for business yeah we know that of course
we know that
Dwight Eisenhower warned about that sort
of thing a long time ago can we there's
nothing new here and this this poor
schlub recruiter for BlackRock trying to
impress some girl on a date
doesn't uh doesn't work out well for him
if you are
in a politically I don't know why I'm
giving advice to the lives here if you
are in a politically contentious
important position and some like smoke
and hot chick comes up to you and wants
to go out on a date and then is just
constantly peppering you with questions
about the most controversial aspects of
your job
yeah
it's on you at that point if you answer
okay you are so the power of women
you'll be so blinded by that okay
it's not surprising but
it's disturbing anyway to see it to hear
it oh
the political system doesn't work the
way that we thought it did it's not
about a bill up on Capitol Hill and
three branches and the people
representing this and that and the other
that's no that's not really how the
political order works and one of the
reasons that Trump was very successful
in 2016 and why he might be successful
again is he called that out in a way
that other Republican politicians hadn't
there was an attack on Trump in 2016.
remember the I forget which other
Republican it was probably multiple said
hey Donald you've donated to Democrats
you've written checks to Democrats
that's why you can't be trusted and he
flipped it he said what are you talking
about I've written checks to every
politician I bought all you people off
I did business and I did business in New
York and at an international scale and
so of course I needed to buy you people
often it was easy to buy you off so I
played both sides of the aisle that's
how the system really works so how am I
going to fix the system because I know
it I've played that game a lot meanwhile
you were just the guys that got bought
it was very persuasive when Trump was
able to convince some people who would
be traditionally ill more left-wing
voters to come on over to him it's
because he was talking about a debate
between the the many and the few between
the people and the elites very different
from from what we hear otherwise between
the Republicans and the Democrats and
the left and the right you're saying no
the system is a little different than
you think what a great video that was
huh make sure you subscribe to the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel ring
that Bell we'll see you next time